hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to fight crab the game
where you fight crab you are crab and
you fight crab amy told me about this
game and said that i have to play it and
looking at it right now i kind of agree
because this seems like something that i
would absolutely have to
learn the basic operations of a crab
ah sure why not it said i had to use a
controller so i
welcome the wonderful world of fight
crap
you are a fighting crab congratulations
thank you use the left and right analog
sticks to manipulate the fret craps
try raising both of your claws above
your shell oh hell yeah
spread them oh i spread them all right
release to ready they're ready positions
okay punch oh damage your opponent by
hitting them with your claws or pincers
oh nice the more damage you deal to your
opponent the easier it is to knock them
over
right if you flip
them onto their cold damp back
oh okay you can close your pincers with
left
bumper right bumper okay your opponent
can be guarded
with left bumper right bumper i see oh
can be broken with scissors what does
that mean
oh oh i'm squeezing you you move
in the button try moving left okay you
can stop moving by pressing another
direction
oh try moving to the right okay you can
dash by pressing twice
okay good try a real crab fight this
time okay so it's going for real
if you flip onto their cold the damp
back you win
oh got ya get down get stay oh come on
okay all right you want to fight crab
you wanna fight you wanna fight oh
[ __ ] pinned baby
this is freaking awesome level up what
do i have do i have anything to level up
with
uh technically yeah but i'm gonna save
until i actually know what i'm doing
this is going great fight uh crustacean
city
the ultimate crustacean crabby street
fight begins here
all right [ __ ] it i'm ready to throw
down let's do this come on you
crab [ __ ] you want a piece of my
shell you want some of this [ __ ] oh
long arm crab never mind i'll come
before you baby
here we go yeah take some take some of
my
my car oh you are just being annihilated
okay charge them
i don't even need to do anything you
freaking destroy yourself
you played yourself long arms okay cool
what
oh oh [ __ ] i keep going i didn't know i
keep going all right you're gonna get a
face full of
car ah
[ __ ] you got you have your arms are way
bigger than mine
okay so i got to be kind of strategic
about how i'm
throwing my punches
oh yeah he's on his back he's on his
back why is this not here we go all
right and
up and we're going to go for a finishing
blow
feels good feels really good feels good
it feels so good
what are you now whatever it doesn't
matter let's charge it let's get
get no you think you can block the
answer is you probably can
ow ow oh you grabbed me oh [ __ ] oh
oh holy crap holy crap
ow let go let go let go like oh you
bastard
no no no no no no no no no no
no no no you don't no you don't know you
don't know you don't
we get you i'm gonna get you oh god i
have no idea how to play
the truth of the matter is i'm just
hitting buttons ah
go push push push push i can push i got
to push i got to push i got to push
push push push push get down stay down
say no no ah i'm being pushed no
yes i win
somehow i won awesome
all right lobster why do you have a
knife and a gun wait why do you
why are you getting a knife and a gun oh
god okay well that gun's not gonna do
you any good when i got my skill oh god
i have no idea how to play
okay maybe this is gonna do you some
good i can't seem to get a punch i'm
going to
god i gotta oh there i go no no no no
no no no if i go to the left i get
knifed if i go to the right i get
shot i'm not sure which one's going to
be better at this point oh i'm going
backwards i just got to hold on for dear
life
oh no i can't seem to get a hold of
anything oh i want to grab that gun
oh no there uh well yeah ah
come on that's not fair no i'm sinking
no money how about we shop bye
knife ooh sword ooh krober butterfly
sword i don't know what that means
tonfa claymore let's go knife
and a crowbar i feel like that's good
yeah let's yeah let's do that
let's do that okay we're gonna go knife
in the left one
krober in the other one get some nice
swing and some night oh yeah this is
gonna be good
all right fight all right we're going
back to it we're gonna back do it oh
we're going back to it oh
it's going down i'm yelling timber oh
you're gonna get it now
okay and swing and up
stab stab swing why am i turned around
can i
wha what turn around you [ __ ]
there we go there we go there we go this
dab stab and swing
and oh god yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
where'd my crowbar go
i lost my crowbar it's okay i don't need
it yeah he lost his knife too
yeah get out of here get out of here
yeah get knife get knife get knife yes
yes yes yes okay
yeah i did it i feel good about myself
where's my crowberg did i lose my
oh what the are those pod racing engines
what i don't understand what you're
doing
what are you doing to me oh god oh god
oh god ow
ow owie okay can you not do that
hold on i lost my knife can i get some
of whatever you've got going on there i
don't know what is with you
lobsters and having a lot of money to be
able to buy this [ __ ] but that's not
cool
oh my god
oh i'm alive i still in it i still need
a baby oh god i'm not in it oh god
someone end the pain oh my god
no no no no no no oh no get him get him
get him get him get him get him get him
get him get him oh god how does he still
have an engine it's okay cause i have
a car a tree
okay uh well there i go yeah that's
that's it for me that's that's it for me
uh that's it for me no maybe not ah
there we go flip
okay all right well we're fine we're all
good no no survive just a little longer
a little longer a little longer did i
yes
[Music]
i did it i won i won the game
i don't know how i did it let me go to
krabi chivalry swords and shells
it is said that there are fabled crab
guards all too familiar with medieval
weapons okay good
but anything's better than having two
jet engines strapped onto oh
all right hair crab i don't know what
that means but that's weird yeah
[Applause]
okay all right just gotta keep up a good
guard there
oh you are annihilated you are
annihilated you are
annihilated you are annihilated you are
annihilated you are annihilated you are
annihilated
you are annihilated you are annihilated
you are annihilated
oh yeah you're annihilated time to say
goodbye
yeah what i'm sorry oh it's just one
after another oh god um
okay maybe i shouldn't have taken so
much damage in the last one
i feel like maybe i should have been a
little more cognizant of my defensive
ability oh no you're annihilated you're
annihilated you're annihilated okay
you're annihilated
you've been an eyelid you're annihilated
okay don't even try to get back oh
you're annihilated
you've been annihilated every part of
you is annihilated and i am amazing okay
hey
oh wait no two at once no one said
anything about that all right whatever
i'll take you on
whatever it's okay i got a crowbar and a
knife yeah one
two one two push and charge and you're
on your back
so why are you not there you go yeah get
your
taint grab you [ __ ] there you go
oh sorry yeah you suck i'm amazing i
know it
we all know we've all known this for so
long there's oh hey snow crab whatever
you know what come up i just
you would never know you're on your back
you're on your back
there we go get you and pin you
ah oh i'm amazing
everything about me is amazing
everything incredibly is amazing while
in the air angling both claws down we'll
call you to fall
i don't know how i would get in the air
i'm not 100 sure how that would happen
so i don't know why that's a tip you
think that i'm going to use
by crab do i want another crab i don't
even know if i want another crab i like
the crab that i've got
i'm willing to bet that the crabs that i
have isn't really as important as having
say a freaking gun i want a gun
i just really i just really want a gun
i think a gun's good i think gun in the
lefty is gonna be real
good i don't know if it's like goes off
automatically or if i actually have to
aim it
all right here we go i'm gonna get you
yeah yeah here comes the gun
okay back up let's back up oh god oh god
oh god oh god oh god
i actually have to aim it oh no oh no
i've lost my knife
oh no gun was a horrible mistake i don't
know how to use this weapon okay here we
go and
boom oh god oh god oh god the gun
oh the gun ain't worth it i can't see
anything oh god
can i please oh get the table out of the
way
i swear to god please please okay here
we go
your time has come yeah three
three really it only does three it does
three damage
does three damage is what it do it does
three
oh my god oh my god get your stupid
up
gun how could you betray me how could
you betray me like this
i'm still spinning i i'm dead just let
me die
let me live out the embarrassment that
is my
loss as it turns out gun
is in fact a bad idea let me try to
upgrade something
hell yeah i don't know what that means
oh yeah
okay let me put the crowbar back
in there all right you're going down
this time buddy don't even try against
me you're gonna lose
i lose the crowbar so quickly why do i
lose what
what what no okay charging
i don't care what you do you're not
gonna get me get your goddamn swords
that's not fair how do you have all this
crap
i want give me a holdi there we go i had
a hold
i got it i got the weapon i got the
weapon away from him get the other one
get the other one get the other one get
the other one get the other one yeah
come on oh please oh please oh please oh
please yeah i've got a lot of damage but
uh
i think i've got this what what did i do
what no no no get him get him get him
yes stay down stay down stay there yes
yes and i got a claymore i don't know if
i get to keep it i don't get to keep it
do i crabby walk in
fire a chinese restaurant who will be
made into a crab ring
oh okay all right so low steaks all
right so everything's fine
oh [ __ ] you are going down buddy i am
not gonna be part of this dish
i'm not gonna be part of this dish here
here
yeah get get get some of this get some
of that get get off that get off the
table get off the table
hey what the what the hell man back up
back up
yeah yeah yeah crab ryan good for you
sorry your family won't be seeing you
ever
again mitten crab oh hey
oh hey god how do i keep losing my
kroger
yeah yeah yeah you're going right off
the table you
[ __ ] yeah goodbye yes sorry about
that you suck
sorry i'm a little bit better than you
sorry i'm in fact way better i need more
money
how do i get more money oh there's more
tutorial oh i didn't even know that
probably more important to learn how to
actually play the game wasn't it
what how'd you do that how how are you
doing that
how are you getting my weapons
unequipped so quickly doesn't matter it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter i'm
gonna break your shell in half you
[ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah get out of here you're go
whoa oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] you're coming with me oh god oh
god no
no please please i want to live oh sweet
baby jesus oh god oh please
not fair not fair at all very unfair in
fact
and we're frozen okay let's try that
again
i gotta say i've never fought crab
before kind of like fighting crab
okay let me see the other tutorial see
learn how to handle weapons
that sounds important that sounds like
something that i would need to know
get ready okay i'm ready go
grabs can hold weapons in both hands
swing
weapons to left and right hitting
opponents with your weapon will cause
more damage
i'm an idiot i was trying to punch with
him the whole time
i didn't know just swinging with him
actually did anything oh
wow
ah that that's helpful that makes a lot
more sense than what i was doing
also sword kind of a lot better than
krober
but that makes a lot of sense all right
let me do what the other tutorial says
okay you can close your pincers i knew
that i was aware of that extend your
arms
okay
oh what wait wait no grab the
bra grab the weapon okay there we go
okay i got this one can you
oh my god can you please just back off
back off
back off let me get this weapon to yours
all right game's over for you
nerd okay all right
there we go all done all easy peasy i
won i'm the best
learn how to run on walls i'm
sorry learn how to run on walls
crabs can walk on walls of course they
can
press y to move on to surrounding walls
what
what what
what what oh that's it
that's all you give me oh okay all right
fine
yeah that that makes sense all right
buddy here we go
and there goes my knife why okay can i
get this can i take this away from you i
feel like i'm supposed to be able to
take this away from you
oh my god oh my god stop stop stop stop
back up back up
back off of me get away from me you
[ __ ]
oh my god get off of my face you [ __ ]
you stupid long arm piece of crap all
right
you want you want you want oh god i
don't want this i don't want this i
don't want this go
go go there we go there we go yeah
yeah now who's on top of oh my god this
is the most harrowing fight i've ever
had in my life
i've i've been in so many fights get get
get
get get yes yes yes no there we go stay
stay stay stay stay stay stay
stay stay get off push push
push yeah yeah
all right good god
it's so hard it's so hard
i guess i'll go for the sword because
for some reason that seems to not
be terrible we're gonna go for sword
and knife okay try this again all right
you
son of a [ __ ] i'm not gonna drop what
is that
oh my god holy crap
what is that supposed to be get get just
go i'm gonna push you i'm
we're pushing i'm pushing just gonna
push you off just go
oh oh you why are you glowing why are
you glowing
oh my god i can't this doesn't make any
sense at all go
okay yeah yeah yes what you get no no no
stay stay
stay i don't get that that doesn't make
sense how do you have a super power
you're a crab you're a coconut crab but
you're still a crab i think
there we go okay all right i did it i
think i'm not sure
man everything just gets close quarters
combat so quickly that you can't do
anything
oh there's two of you okay this is gonna
be a fair fight yeah okay
okay well i'm doing a lot of damage to
one of them okay i need to back off
oh i lost my sword okay where is it i
can go find it i know it's got to be
here somewhere unless it got thrown off
the map which i think it actually might
have gotten thrown off the map
okay bottle you're gonna get bottle oh
well no never mind you're gonna get
absolutely nothing
oh god oh god that's a sword right in my
mouth that's
why is the sword right in my mouth no
not today not today not today not today
not to get the sword out of my mouth
just go oh my god get off of me you suck
i will live
[Music]
i apologize because this video just
happens to me see me screaming into the
mic
yelling about how the crabs have wronged
me and i feel
like i'm totally justified in my rage
and i forgot that the game crashes if
you try to continue after losing because
it just wants to punish you for being
bad at the game
and it's not that i'm bad at the game i
might be the best fight crabber in the
world at the moment but
in this particular instance they are
wronging me so i will make sure that
they are wronged in return
why do they get spears why are you
surrounded oh my god they're surrounding
me and i've somehow lost my knife
already and i'm about to lose my sword
this is just wonderful you know what i
feel like there's some very obvious
favoritism going on here
okay you're done you're done you're done
and now you you you i've met 135
damage but that doesn't matter to me
because i'm gonna get oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] no no no no no no no no
no no
no i will be victorious oh god why am i
oh god why am i flipping oh stop stop
just get i'm trying to back away from
you but every time i back away i flip on
my bed
why no no no no
how am i supposed to get away from you
if every time i go backwards i flip on
my freaking back
okay that one okay and there goes both
my weapons
that's okay i'm gonna get one back right
now
i'm gonna get no apparently not
apparently i don't get it back even
though i went right over it
okay yeah and then they're just gonna
wail on me what what
what what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] how
does that one have no damage no i don't
want to look at that one i would look at
the other one what the [ __ ] what
back up back up back up just get them
off get them off get them off get them
off get them off get them off no not me
not me not me go for
just oh really oh what in the hell
what i'm so
weirdly into this and yet i'm very
frustrated the mechanics don't make
sense
there's no strategy to be had in any of
this
guaranteed there's no strategy
whatsoever
like if you're hoping for a game with
some strategy
i i mean this this ain't it chief like
this
this one guarantee there's nothing
there's no way
someone could actually be any sort of
good at this it's just a flail fest
and that's fine it's fine i'm not going
to talk about why i'm
i'm justifying why it seems like i'm bad
but i'm not really because i'm actually
quite
capable i bet i bet i'm like top ten you
better just i'm gonna win this now
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah you could stay
down i'll hold you there yes
yeah where am i going let's go sailing
off the edge of the map
great all right i'm good i'm good enough
enough i feel good
i feel really really good but that is it
for now so that is fight crab
good game if you want to have some sick
crab on crab action
get fight crab but it is not free
unfortunately
but it is cool so i do like it there are
some things to like about it so
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you want to check out fight crap
there's a link in the description check
out other weird games that i played
linked in the description as well or
over there in the suggested videos
and thank you everybody for watching and
as always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
you